the four-door station wagon i'm going to
confess something to you
i love a station wagon i know i know
they're like the most boring suburban
car ever except they're not they're
totally spacious totally useful and they
handle like a real car
but nobody loves a wagon anymore there
were 215 different models of cars sold
in the u.s last year you want to know
how many of them were wagons
and that number is shrinking thank
goodness then for mercedes-benz those
guys have been supplying americans with
a proper wagon for decades
is the e63 s amg for manic wagon it has
a decidedly insane in the membrane v8
twin turbocharged at five and a half
liters producing
577 horsepower and 590 pound speed of
torque i still don't really know how
torque works but i know that that is a
lot of torque so what we have here is a
car with more power than a ferrari 458
italia a porsche 911 turbo s or an aston
martin vanquish
and you can take this one to ikea or you
can take it here to raceway park in
englishtown new jersey where i am going
to do some positively non-domestic
things to this car
tell the folks at raceway that you're
coming to test the station wagon on
their strip and people get a little
curious i gotta look for a family car it
moves
we decided to race the e63 against the
clock and see how fast it could run a
quarter mile
so after multiple passes this car posted
a best quarter mile time of 11.86
seconds let me put that in perspective
that is faster than the 2014 corvette
stingray now at 118 000 this car clearly
isn't for everyone but if you have the
means this might just be the greatest
most ridiculous family car ever built